بيتزا من اليوم بدات توقيت حلقتنا مع
بدايه ونهايه حدث عالمي شاغل الناس
والدنيا من 20 نوفمبر وبدايه المباراه
النهائيه بين منتخبي الارجنتين وفرنسا على
لقب بطل كاس العالم 20 22 في نهايه
مونديال شغل العالم طوال شهر بالمنافسه
والمفاجاه طبعا ومجاهدين المنتخبين
الحاصلين مرتين على لقب بطل كاس العالم
والمنافس اليوم لنيل النجمه الذهبيه
الثالثه لواحد فيهم الناس على اعصابهم مين
راح يحصلوا اللقب اليوم وحملات الدعم
للفريقين من الصوت وشغله عقول وقلوب
الملايين اما الين المسي قالوا ان نصيب
الاكبر من الدعم اليوم ويبدا ان السبب
بالاضافه لانجازاته وبهارات الكبيره اللي
قدمها لمنتخبنا وانديته الكره العالم او
لكره القدم العالميه بشكل عام يبدو انه
كمان هذه المباراه راح تكون اخر مباراه
بخوضها في كاس العالم فهذا كمان عامل
زياده نوع من الحمل لكن بشكل عام الاجواء
الحماسيه والخصوصيه الرياضيه والحاله اللي
عملها المونديال حقيقه ما بتتكرر لانه
بالاساس صعب يكون في حدث يجمع الملايين
على متابعته همم بنفس الحماس من اول يوم
لاخر دقيقه
وكثير من المتعصبين لكره القدم من بعد ما
بينتهي المونديال بيعانوا من الوحده
والعصبيه والكابه بسبب الفراغ وخروج جدول
النشاطات من موضوعات شيقه ما فيش عربي
اكتئاب ما بعد البطوله
يعني واللي من اعراضه الحزن والكسل وقضاء
ساعات في متابعه اخبار اللاعبين المصابين
وتنقلاتهم واحتفالات الفريق اللي فاز وهذه
الاعراض حلها يا جماعه كالتاليه يعني لازم
يجرب الشخص لان اصحابه بعد الان لازم
يمارسن نشاطات جماعيه ما يهمل العمل او
الدراسه في نفس الوقت ما يشوف اعاده
مباريات لان الهواس الرياضي بيخليه يحزن
اكثر يعني بكل بساطه يحاول يرجع لحياته
يعني عادي كيف ما كانت قبل المونديال
[موسيقى]